hey 42 here the USA is obligated by
treaty to go to war for 67 different
countries if they were to find
themselves in conflict welcome to RIF
the very first assassination attempt on
a u.s. president was stopped when the
then President Andrew Jackson beat his
assailant brutally with a cane before
being stopped by a nearby congressman
mongooses were introduced to Hawaii to
control the invasive rats population
however rats are nocturnal and mongooses
are diurnal Hawaii now has a problem
with both Spain cheated in the 2000
Summer Paralympics 10 of the 12 players
on their roster were quote-unquote
encouraged to pretend to be stupid and
actually had no mental disability a man
named Adam Armstrong changed his name to
Adam West by deed poll to match his
misprinted airline ticket as it was
cheaper than paying the airlines admin
fee a child that was Bart's age when the
Simpsons first premiered would now be
the same age as Homer high intelligence
is linked to higher rates of mental
illness such as schizophrenia and
bipolar disorder meaning the mad
scientist stereotype has some ground in
reality surgical masks in Japan are not
only used to prevent sickness what are
used for fashion warmth and sometimes
avoiding conversation with strangers
Englishman Frank Vikatan fought in both
world wars was drafted into two
Antarctic exhibitions developed a golf
course was the hero of a novel killed
bears wrote major motion pictures
treasure huntin in Costa Rica and
married an Earl's granddaughter there's
a strange phenomenon in the film
industry called twin movies where eerily
similar movies get released around the
same time and not on purpose
for example the prestige and the
illusionist amps under books life
Olympus has fallen and why
house down friends with benefits and no
strings attached doorknobs made out of
brass automatically disinfect themselves
in about 8 hours through the oligo
dynamic effect the gaping holes that
buildings in Hong Kong usually have are
called dragon windows or dragon holes
they are put into buildings so they
don't block a dragon's passage from the
hills to the sea underneath the striped
fur of a tiger is striped skin which
helps it preserve the camouflage effect
mark spitz 9 time Olympic champion
jokingly told a Russian swim team coach
in 1972 that his mustache increased his
speed in the water deflecting water away
from his mouth the next year every
Russian swimmer was sporting one in 1982
Universal Studios sued Nintendo over
alleged similarities between King Kong
and Donkey Kong
not only did Universal lose but the
court found a King Kong game licensed by
Universal that was actually in violation
of Nintendo's copyrights Franklin D
Roosevelt once accidentally walked in on
a naked Winston Churchill when Roosevelt
apologized
Churchill replied the Prime Minister of
Great Britain has nothing to hide from
the President of the United States
thanks for the view subscribe for more
you